Nazis zombies this is my kind of movie
nice it's also a really solid war film
and you guys have this incredible
sequence right out of the gate with that
aerial plane can you talk me through a
little bit what that was like to shoot
hard it was hard it was seven days you
couldn't really get out or maybe five
days you couldn't get out of the plane
once you were up there because it was
raised about 30-40 feet in the air yeah
and it was hot it was stinky you had her
parachutes on that kind of crunched your
back so you're up in there for the 10
camp of five hours and it was just
difficult and then the plane starts
shaking and you're trying to you know
yeah and you eat I thought it did you
just say that we had we had a you know
50 pounds of gear on the part right yeah
it's just like squeeze you done so yeah
when we finally we'd probably get off
that that rig what every three hours
we'd get offers yeah yeah we tried to
make it like scheduled breaks around
like three hours or so and you have you
know 20 30 guys and these parachute
you know uniforms and everybody's trying
to get out and just going down these
staircases you can't maneuver your
weapons it was just it was hard it was
tough and also the boat it felt less I
don't recall again blow everybody's it
was odd the plane was actually all these
huge mechanical Stokes basically which
they had this the belt you know must've
spent a ton of money on this thing and
it basically would make the thing rock
is more turbulent came and you know they
could control a doorless stuff and
within ten minutes of doing they were
like yeah it's not you guys just gonna
have to shake in your seat so if there
was that ugly point there it does look
great so your hard work was worth it
yeah um the other thing I love is that
it's pretty clear that you guys got to
work with some practical effects when it
comes to the monster elements as
performers what does that mean to you to
have something real to interact with
it's really important and for this I
think it showed why doing other things
that have been mostly CGI you don't know
what's there you don't really know what
you're reacting to there's a guy with
like a tennis ball in a green suit like
acting like a forty foot monster and
it's like not the same and because the
story allowed for practical elements to
be made to be done in the movie the way
they built them were they built them so
well that when you looked across the
room and you see somebody who's actually
transforming and they look like they
veins coming out and it's real it does
it you don't have to imagine it's there
you're doing it it's in front of you in
that scene is you know probably the best
example of it when he in transforms yeah
this is an amazing job with the
prosthetics and stuff like that I mean
the they attach the the level of detail
they happen it's like really incredible
that was a cool scene - yeah how is it
for you guys dealing with the bad robot
level of secrecy and how happy are you
now to be able to actually talk about
this we still can't really talk about
everything leave some things a surprise
but it's you know at times it can be a
little difficult but um but luckily you
can trust JJ I mean I understand before
we didn't have the actual script or at
least Ian and I didn't have the actual
script until we were ready to go until
we got the job and we're ready to go so
you're putting a lot of faith in in
people and you know luckily with JJ you
can and with Billy Ray and Mark you know
that they're great writers and tell
wonderful stories so it's a little it
can be a little you know you're chomping
at the bit because you want to see it
you want to know what's going on but you
know you just trust them and you get by
yeah yeah yeah how many how many people
have been like Cloverfield movie there
was a lot of and there was a lot of us
eating we need once said we were
chemically
sure yeah I remember the last one they
made like the guys didn't know they were
making it until later
yeah yeah right yeah exactly you guys
also um it's a big bouquet but it's a
pretty small group of characters and you
guys went through that training together
what was that experience like coming out
of that and then going into shooting it
was really valuable the boot camp for a
lot of different reasons in terms of you
know in a military sense learning
learning about you know I know I don't
have any experience of that kind of
world
and also it gave you a small I think
insight and to you know record these
night patrols sometimes and a small
insight to what it would be to be a
young guy that's you know thrown into a
into a soldier's uniform and taken into
another country and not knowing really
where the enemy is and you know and but
then also just the bonding experience
you know it was tough we would go I
would do personal training and do all
these you know do the night patrols and
get up early and and all that kind of
stuff but at nighttime we would sit
around the campfire and just get to know
one another and there was there was a
history that was kind of created there I
think I mean it kind of gave us a
natural rhythm that I think helps make
the relationship in the film work we
just started learning kind of each
other's rhythms and help everyone sense
of humor and how people operated and it
just really brought us together yeah
your dynamic with the child actor is one
of like the highlight
you know what they always say about
we're going to kids and animals but I
always hear that's actually not true
it's fun to work with kids that guys 56
years old now he's wonderful easy young
kid from outside of Paris one of the
first things he's done just a total
sweetheart little rambunctious - did you
say see there's many talking the
shoulder you turn to go hey man how's it
going and he would just punches hard the
kids so they Julius with some sort of
stroke of genius I heard us together I
guess but yeah it was really it was
really these really lovely really great
yeah he's all scene-stealer this is kind
of a different role for you as well
gonna play the grizzled tough guy a
little bit did you do you lean into that
you enjoy it I
yeah I did I had fun doing it doing it
cuz it was different and it was exciting
to be something else you know you always
try and mix it up a little bit no I do
be doing the same thing over and over
again and this was a this was made so
much fun by the people you got to do
with I mean I know that sounds cheesy
but it was because if sometimes you if
you feel if you think if I felt like I
was on an island that like I'd be like
doing a good job or no you know there's
a million times where people can were
like picking everybody up that's the
definition of having great people in the
cast so it wasn't just about really you
know what you were doing it was about
what everybody was doing and everybody
fed off that which was pretty cool
yeah and for you you have that big scene
did you have to do any special like
physical training to prepare for those
moments yeah yeah twice Lee what I
actually did remember there was one
point where we've talked about it since
we're like at the end of the half with
good reasons we might not cut the movie
where basically there's this moment
where I kept where these tears just
unload in their clips
big time and I they wanted me to do like
react ability but it but when you watch
it back I've done really it just looks
like I'm auditioning yeah and so they so
I mean they cut it you really yeah but
it was so nice is I couldn't get this
thing and I was like hey Julius was
coming in and it would be really patient
with me and I just remember like
everyone kind of come out to me and just
being like
you